[Musique]
excusez mon pour
mon comportement mais c'est mon premier
podium donc du coup je suis un peu
stressée quelqu'un qui a l'habitude de
faire des buzz aujourd'hui peut-être
juste à elle l'objet d'un buzz on sait
jamais
merci bonsoir à tous ce soir je vais
vous expliquer une histoire d'une dame
qui abidjan et ali pour acheter un
produit les teams et quand elle arrivait
au supermarché
elle achète le produit le produit
qu'elle a acheté sept points produits
mais ne le savais pas et quand elle
arrivait à la maison
elle a utilisé le produit elle a vu que
c'est un produit dit il elle a mis ça
dans solvay et il y avait des bulles et
quand il ya des bulles on peut pas
consommer le produit est ludique et
c'est pas bon
la dame elle était fâchée comme moi je
suis quelqu'un j'aime les buzz les a
fait rage et où elle est venue me voir
et me dit tiens sam gensou si j'achète
un produit mais c'est gâté comme on fait
deux mois qu'on parle à moi je me fais
le reste
et elle m'a remis ou ce qui a comme
information une plateforme sur facebook
qui permet aux gens de de porter plainte
à cette entreprise est là quand on a
fait je vous assure que la dame depuis
la france le patron le grand patron
depuis la france a appelé la dame ou lui
demander vraiment plu présenté ses
excuses parce que le sien parce que la
dame à faire
il ya eu d'autres personnes derrière qui
se sont dits abc vrai bon si j'ai acheté
ce produit c'est pas bon et des faux
produits c'est rentrer si sa sortie sur
la voyez un peu
l'engouement d'un buzz je me présente je
suis novice en bas on digital est
aujourd'hui
vous montrez tennis eu la percée d'un
buzz il ya déjà entendu parler d'un buzz
et apparemment les gens n'aiment pas
trop les buzzy si le buzz c'est un
phénomène de bouche à oreille ça c'est
ce que le dictionnaire ou di meo temps
réel on est en afrique et en temps
normal un buzz c'est quoi
je veux montrer une image je sais pas
qui a déjà vu des postes une fois sur
facebook voilà et c'est une entreprise
dont seraient pas dire le nom
mais s'il voulait plus voir est le petit
il ay la beauté et non encore du monde
il a monté son petit tapis mois et s'ils
sont simplement c'est écrit le cge plus
court de la jeune
on est africain il ya beaucoup
d'artistes qui n'ont pas beaucoup aimé
ça et faut dire que ça a beaucoup joué
sur l'image de l'entreprise en question
l'histoire fatale là c'est la partie je
sais pas si je dois prendre une minute
avant de raconter l'histoire où je dois
la raconter maintenant
mon histoire pas talent
je vous assure que
je sais pas si quelqu'un dans une dans
la même salle a eu ce problème en 2012
j'ai créé une page
était mon entreprise que j'ai nommé
sondés baby.com et la page dès 2012 à
j'avais environ plus de 1 million 300
mille floureux parce que jamais les buzz
et août dont je me suis plus souvent
c'est dedans et je vous assure
maintenant je reçois une notification de
facebook mais disons
vous êtes bloqué ou trois jours bon je
me suis dit tu rajoutes s'est pas
beaucoup ce sont douze
c'était ça me permet de me reposer un
peu après les trois jours je reçois une
notification tout est dit votre page est
définitivement supprimée et facebook
waouh
waouh pas je vous assure que c'était
plus qu'un choc moi parce que
il arrivait d'un moment je vais demander
qu'est ce qui s'est passé qu'est ce que
j'ai fait j'ai pas publier une image
insolite ou ou qu'ils en arrivent là
c'était des primaires 1 million 300
savez c'est le travail de combien de
jours deux premiers de mois
de combien d'années la jolie investi
là-dedans et quand ça s'est passé je me
suis repliée depuis trois jours je
n'arrivais pas du tout à manger les
audiences et facebook il faut laisser ça
les mots c'est un bon business
c'était mon business et du coup pendant
les trois jours j'ai eu des personnes
qui m'ont dit bah écoute est pas la fin
du monde
il peut créer une autre page et puis tu
vas voir je dis c'est un million trois
cent mille follower ça pour l'avoir à un
million c'est pas facile quand avec les
conseils des personnes et j'ai pris goût
je me suis relevé je suis allé réveiller
une même page
pour récréer la page n'a pas été du tout
facile parce que quelque chose me disait
où tu fais en tissu qui laisse
lis ça je vais pas à l'écouté je vais
continuer j'ai créé la page
la première page qui était supprimé j'ai
vu que ce que je faisais là bas est un
peu plat donc j'ai essayé d'améliorer un
peu pour la deuxième page du coup mes
anciens abonnés ont commencé à venir
petit à petit et it a pity petit à petit
jusqu'à ce que au bout d'un an je me
suis retrouvé à plus de 800 me au loin
et ses 809 euros pour moi je me suis dit
oh
au moins c'est pas loin des murs 300 mhz
et 800 me + 1 million 300 ça fait
quelque chose de bien c'est beaucoup
mais qui ont fait au moins 1 million 300
bon c'est pas grave
bon du coup je suis resté là dessus
je me suis concentré de phase i qui
fallait et un matin
j'ai reçu une notification je vous
assure que leurs deux fils casque en jeu
que j'ai reçu j'avais peur parce que je
regarde je vois ouais quand c'est le
message est un point heure où le chiffre
2 août
quand j'ai vu jeudi et mon dieu est-ce
que ça
j'aurais galles pezous mehdi vous êtes
bloqué ou de 30 jours alléluia quand tu
joues
bon donc m'ont dit non il faut laisser
tisser les histoires dit facebook là
c'est pour les blancs police tisse sa
toile chine appliqué
j'aurais dit j'ai pris mon mal en
patience pendant les 30 jours je me suis
concentré à fait autre chose
je suis un peu éloigné d'abidjan par un
peu dans la brousse pour essayer
d'oublier tout ce qui est buzz tout ce
qui est like pour tout oublier et plus
rester dans mon coin et le 28ème jour
j'ai pris là repas bio et quand je suis
arrivé à abidjan
peux tu es tellement pressés à minuit
signe je regardais déjà voici la page
était déjà arrivé et je vous assure deux
heures seront pas là
le nom de ma part je ne vois pas
des démons peut-être la connexion que
j'utilise c'est pas une bonne connexion
faut que je change de connexions dont je
prie une connexion de notre parti n'est
pour pouvoir le faire
je retrouve page a plein d'amis j'ai des
bâtons l'institut et safari mais je ne
vois pas ma page et non faussée avec
l'autre donc navigateur varicent a passé
on a essayé tous les navigateurs qu'on
connaît rien et ça chie la page bene
est supprimé pour une deuxième fois
moins
de thaci
je sais pas si c'était le ciel et puis
les nuages qui tombait sur mobile si
c'était ou qui tombait sur moi les gens
me voyaient en pixels et rire sera faite
doute un million trois cents supprimer
deal est plus de 800000 euros
il permet d' il est donc je sais pas
quoi faire
je vous assure que je suis tombé malade
je suis tombé gravement malade pendant
deux semaines je suis allé voir le
médecin le messin mais dit on va faire
les mêmes états tiers petit palu que
derrière on a fait les examens
y'a papa lui qui arrive y'a rien que
derrière le gars me dis mais c'est la
première fois que je vois un malade
l'aude où on ne connaît pas le nom de la
maladie et c'est une dame qui m'a dit
est-ce que tu as faim pour le mettre à
petite copine m'avait dit de copines sur
facebook peut-être c'est le goût mais
qui va donner
kiva rendu malade temps du coup je me
suis repliée et pendant ces deux
semaines je vous assure que c'était pas
du tout facile est vrai on rit mais
était vraiment à battre vraiment abattu
arrivé au moment je me disais bon est ce
que ça vaut la peine de franco et déjà
tout perdu
et une autre voiture mais dit vas-y tout
mais dit non au feu laisser vas-y laisse
vase il est
enfin si
j'ai pris goût à
c'était une personne courage monsieur
réuni petit appétit
extrayez une troisième page 2 comme on
le dit deux sans toi
jamais deux sans trois et je vous assure
où les chrétiens au nom du père du fils
et saint-esprit
je me suis dit oh mon dieu le tescou là
j'espère que ça va pas ça va me toucher
positivement et la troisième page que
j'écris
changer un peu j'ai commencé à faire des
directs des live mais les lâches que je
faisais
était de retrouver encore divona dollar
trop surtout nos artistes
je faisais passer son bout et les gens
aimaient beaucoup et je commençais à
avoir petit à petit mais c'est faux loi
c'était difficile parce que pour avoir
moins de dix fois par jour on vraiment
être un cas du buzz je ne remonteront
j'ai tout fait juste quand je suis
arrivé les pompes à eau plus de son 1000
comme il faut louer et les seins nus
follower quand je me réveille matin
avant de toucher mon ordinateur
ah mon dieu voici ma page facebook si tu
aimes à prier parce que j'avais vraiment
peur
et de là je sais pas qu'est ce qui s'est
passé
la notification de facebook tu as donc
des christ et je vous assure
quand j'ai reçu la notification on me
dit vous avez publié des images ils vont
à l'encontre du fise bon ça c'était pour
24 seulement les vingt quatre mois je me
reposer et après le 24 je vous assure le
fameux messages de notification une
enveloppe avec un petit point rouge
la page a été supprimée
là c'était une dépression pour moi
je me suis totalement rangé
dans un endroit je voulais pas parler à
quelqu'un j'ai fait mais mon téléphone
j'ai fait me to
des personnes qui me donnait des
c'est le courage nova this aval et et
kate ne soit pas déprimer haute avant
moment je me disais j'ai dit peut-être
200 cette façon que l'on fait et j'en
suis fan
[Musique]
mais j'ai pris courage se retourner en
brousse
je les ivoiriens on aime dit moi je tape
et pour tout trois fois comme on te dit
tu as ta paix poteau s'est dit tout ce
que tu as fais pas ça pour moi c'est
trois fois à gauche à droite c'est pas
si un autre coin mais franchement était
vraiment déprimant
je me souviens ma mère me disait
les ordinateurs rendre dans les partis
c'est parti
j'ai dit à la vienne
c'est la nouvelle technologie moi je
connais pas papy tu connais ta blait
mahfoud
le vieux airs à son ami dizaine pucelle
quand tu te tournes fois il peut
autoriser une deuxième fois
une troisième fois et matt bière une qui
veut sont et ypres ou moins musclées et
trois fois ce sont près de la poupe on
ne baisse pas les bras mais vas-y et
j'ai continué
et ton village vont là bas il ya souvent
des problèmes d'où je dis bon ovine et
abidjan pour fort et c'est là bas
chaumet dit vas-y
jallet mais je me disais
trois fois mais je dise à un moment
j'avais peu d'édifices vous pensé quand
je disais le nom automatiquement j'avais
des problèmes dont tous mes comptes ont
été supprimés depuis tout à zéro ça dit
tout ce que j'avais comme compte
pour travailler ou chez les reprendre à
zéro
et quand j'ai repris à zéro et que je
faisais pas avec la première page la
deuxième et la troisième page et
commencer à faire avec la dernière page
il commençait à plus de données et quand
je me suis donné je me rappelle diane ja
à l'époque j'avais mis hors jeu fun
direct y avait plus de 2000 personnes
connectées via un concurrent qui m'a
appelé et puis mes demandes à temps mais
des live les directeurs et sponsorise
pour guy léger sponsorise pas pourquoi
kim une review pour se créer quatre
millions
bon j'ai 1000 jeux des livres mons et
qui s'est moqué les oies se voit
bon du coup il m'a mis la puce à
l'oreille je commençais à faire me
dirait un peu à la manière d'une chaîne
de télé quand je fais le dirait je fais
des jingles d'un trou après je fais des
despotes publicité pour insérer tous
assez au début je savais pas mais il a
fallu ces trois pages supprimées me
remettre en cause ou cherchent à savoir
qu'est-ce que je peux faire pour aller
au delà de mes limites et j'ai fait cela
quand j'ai commencé au début ce n'était
pas du tout facile
il ya des gens j'ai des amis qui sont
venus me voir on m'appelait nos facebook
parce que moi quand je sers et facebook
où monsieur prime mais j'ai pas pris
leurs propos bourgade pour le garder
dans mon coeur je me suis dit nos
facebook ou moi c'est un challenge et je
vais relever ce challenge de travailler
petit à petit à petit à petit et je vous
je me suis retrouvé à une donc il faut
louer est une entreprise qui m'a
contacté et m'a demandé à gbagbo une
phase où les gens m'appellent beaucoup
ça on recherche une page ou de baby mais
a fait le tour ne retrouve pas la page
président mon cas j'ai dit si j'ai dit
que c'était super marché de la carte
mais je pense à jean jeudi à l'ats perso
je suis effectivement j'avais une page
mais j'ai fait mais pour travaux
il m'a dit mais vous savez je fais mais
votre page pour travaux et depuis j'ai
fermé pour travaux
c'est la première fois qu'il entend ça
en tandem enfants lt riaj de prière m
audio et visuel que je prends ce
business et après on a eu à échanger
il m'a dit et direct m'intéresse mais
organise un événement et dubaï et
j'aimerais voir avec toi comment ça va
se passer au tout ça j'ai dit dans mon
coeur
[Musique]
habib demba dia d'espagne c'est ici on
le fait quand tu veux que unafam h3n2
droit ici on le faire aussi voir dont je
fais comme ça et je t'aide leghari mais
saluer mais moi j'avais la mer derrière
parce que je croisais bien et quand on
l'a fini il m'a dit on voit moins
lapopie de ton passeport quand j'aurai
la copie du pansement il a fait tout
visa tous ont reçu le biais et quand
j'ai reçu le biais du suis allé voir
manière ma mère pardon il y a
j'ai pas pris by step a pris deux
cailloux j'appuie smartphones mais avec
une eau le peu d'abonnés
je suis allé à dubaï pour participer à
un événement
dans l'un des plus grands hôtels et pas
si vous connaissez le brouillard av
et là que j'ai pu faire
là ma première ma première mission
après dubaï
et ce qui est intéressant je prenais des
photos et puis je postais ça et la page
donc les gens voient les 30000 à l'appui
il faut déjà fait photoshop ou virgile
hors jeu par votre choix j'ai fait et
c'est la réalité et à partir de la barre
jeu je me suis plus de dix ans des buzz
est vrai buzz commence à poursuivre les
gens au pouvoir récupérer les abonnés
mais je vous assure aujourd'hui d'autres
plus de la page j'ai créé mon site
internet et tout ce qui est comme ma
fille rage maintenant j'ai changé de
stratégie
les gens qui font des pensées pu mettre
de l'hôtesse non le même petit
approchant le voir la suite
l'ixus on va directement ce mot si on
commence à travailler
professionnellement
et je vous assure
[Musique]
aujourd'hui mon quillet j'avais une
malade n'a pas suffi d une maladie de
goût mais les réseaux sociaux tout ce
que nous faisons dans la vie pouvons en
art il arrive il arrive des fois où on a
des problèmes on s'est dit bon ça arrive
à tout le monde
vrai ça arrive à tout le monde mais toi
tu n'es pas tout le monde les autres qui
peuvent être tout le monde le toi tu
n'es pas tout le monde toi tu es unique
canton jours et dont le travail que tu
fais et l'innovation qui paye et moi je
me suis donné à fond dans l'innovation
chaque jour je criais par jour j'ai crié
et quand je fais mes buzz est pas en
plus des images de marange est toujours
avoir des vidéos et vous savez quand
cette vidéo il ya plus de regards
étaient mon histoire je ne souhaite pas
à quelqu'un que ça passe soit supprimé
trois fois
mais quelque part si c'est bon parce que
ça te font ch quel que soit ce que les
gens monter dit
wam mpc qui te plaît ne copie pas ce que
l'autre fait parce que vous n'êtes pas
vous n'avez pas la même destinée que le
tas promu est plus grand est ce que les
zones on te promets de vous re vinci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]